hey youtubers it's Charlie so really big
stuff happening this week Fantastic
Four's premiering and there's new
Deadpool footage red band footage so
they just aired a crossover clip like a
Fantastic Four featurette with Deadpool
attached to it so I'm gonna play that
then I'm gonna break down ultimate
Fantastic Four and explain what the
movie is doing then i'll explain how fox
is planning on crossing over all of its
characters in the future yes it's true
Fox is working up towards a shared type
of universe you see with the the Marvel
movies but they're not quite there yet
I'll explain how that will work after
the clip so here we go when I grow up I
want to be the first person to teleport
himself even if you could build it I've
already built it is it next to your
flying car I'm not working on that
anymore dr. storm we gave you six years
and millions of dollars and you gave us
nothing what's different now
Reed Richards
you know the answers to questions we
don't even know - I ask you don't let
any of these lab coats give you any crap
I well if I do I know who to call the
muscle
I wanted to create a place where we
could learn more about our planet maybe
even saved maids my daughter's suit I
gotta say it's fun having you here
myself
Johnny breathe he can build anything
what you've created here is incredible
you guys sure you're in the best shape
to be done this yeah
we're good
sometimes
you're looking to discover one thing and
you find something else for abs survive
in the aftermath
these survivors all exhibit unique
physical conditions
these are going to change the world
he promised me you wouldn't use my kids
as weapons
because of our abilities
new locks the four of us away well we're
not the ones you should fear what murder
you know know anything about what's
coming what is coming
this is the end of your world
and the beginning of mine
[Music]
but wait there's more it's me Deadpool
with a special offer C fan four in
theaters this Friday and I'll throw in
my Deadpool trailer for free for an
erection lasting longer than four hours
pat yourself on the back so in case you
didn't see my last Fantastic Four video
it's it's been a little while this movie
is based on the ultimate Fantastic Four
canon which is different from the Marvel
six one six characters Marvel six one
six Universe is like the main universe
if you've been reading the comics
they've been doing Secret Wars so that's
all changed but but for the most part
think of this as being based on ultimate
Fantastic Four even though that no
longer exists in the comics what
happened is is that Brian Michael Bendis
when he created the Ultimate Universe
like he created ultimate spider-man
rewrote his origin story did the same
thing for ultimate Fantastic Four so a
lot of the dynamics between the
characters is the same but their origin
story's a little bit different it's a
little bit more sci-fi than fantasy
Fantastic Four has always been like a
science-based team I mean Reed Richards
is like one of the smartest scientists
on the planet but a lot of their Stan
Lee origin story is tied up in really
fantastical things ultimate Fantastic
Four just tried to bring that closer to
straight-up sci-fi so that influenced
the whole look of the film like it's
just a little bit darker a lot more
sci-fi so Doctor Doom for instance
probably not going to be using magic in
the film in the comics the difference is
is that you know Doctor Doom has like
one foot in the realm of magic one foot
in the realm of science the actor that
plays Doom in this movie Toby Kebbell
actually said that a long time ago there
was a lot of rumors about the film about
his origin story being completely
different from the comics him being some
kind of computer hacker he's since said
that that's not true like his origin
story is still the same they don't
directly address dooms backstory in the
movie they just they don't have time to
get to it but it's still the same his
mother was still a gypsy he's still from
Latveria none of that has been changed
the big difference and this is all part
of the ultimate Fantastic Four comics is
the way they get their powers like how
they come together the way they weave in
some of their like the really familiar
locations of the Fantastic Four universe
like the Baxter building
so as different as this movie seems like
I know it seems like it's a dramatic
departure from the Fantastic Four it's
actually based on the comics just
not a comic that a lot of people have
read way more people have read like the
main Fantastic Four storyline then
ultimate Fantastic Four the underlying
MacGuffin of the story is the end zone
at least in the ultimate Fantastic Four
comics Reed Richards is trying to
develop a teleporter but unbeknownst to
him dr. doom messes with it and it sends
him to this alternate dimension called
the end zone now this is where like I
think the movie is going to depart from
the ultimate Fantastic Four comics
there's like like a big villain
associated with the end zone it gets
really crazy I think the movies gonna
play down that aspect and Doctor Doom
will just be the main villain the movie
will just tone down some of the more
ridiculous elements of the comic but
it's that first teleportation accident
that gives them their powers it's you
know it's like the stand-in for solar
radiation in the Stan Lee origin story
so however you feel about the origin
story in this movie you could really
have Brian Michael Bendis and Mark
Millar to thank the other really
noticeable change too is dr. storm he's
kind of like the lead scientist at the
Baxter building which is like this this
military funded Institute that he's
created kind of like a version of
Professor Xavier school for the gifted
like he just he brings all the smartest
minds together to try and create new
technology but as the clip says he's
been unsuccessful until he finds Reed
Richards and brings him in so that
that's like when the team starts to come
together one of the other small changes
too is that in the Ultimate Comics they
also run into the Inhumans because Fox
doesn't have the film rights to them
we're not gonna see Inhumans in the
movie but it's really not to the end of
that initial Ultimates run that they
become the official Fantastic Four team
so even though we see them in the
costumes in the trailer I'm not I'm not
expected to see a lot of like the
Fantastic Four trappings a lot of the
traditional trappings till the end of
the film as of Secret Wars there is no
standalone Fantastic Four comic so most
of those characters are gonna appear in
and around secret wars and the tie-ins
eventually they'll start a new Fantastic
Four comic but it's probably gonna be a
little awhile if you haven't been
reading in the comics lately Marvel is
in the process of rebooting every single
comic book that it has it's going down
right now in secret Ward so if you're
not reading Secret Wars you should check
it out it's really crazy and awesome you
can find it on comiXology okay so I know
everyone's asking where does this
Fantastic Four movie fit in Fox's
universe of Marvel characters because it
looks
like they're trying to head to a shared
universe especially since they attach
this Deadpool clip to the trailer as it
stands right now there are a bunch of
x-men characters inside the Deadpool
movie Deadpool is an official spin-off
of x-men apocalypse so they're kind of
already there in a low-level fantastic
forwards a little bit different in that
they're trying to reinvigorate the
franchise so I think once they find a
formula that they really like once they
find something that's really successful
then they'll try and integrate it in a
bigger way because really everybody
wants to get to a situation where we see
something on screen that looks a little
bit like secret Wars where characters
from all kinds of different titles can
interact with each other because some of
the most interesting stories with like
x-men characters are big crossover
events and it's a little trickier to do
that just based on the way that they've
done movies in the past even on the
Marvel side of things with with the
Avengers franchise it took them several
years of very successful movies before
they could do Avengers but that was
always the long-term plan so in Fox's
grand scheme of things in their
long-term plan yes they will do x-men
crossover franchises a good example that
is like the starjammers like that would
be their version of guardians of the
galaxy like a space-based movie with a
really weird group of characters and
eventually I do think we'll see a Fox
Marvel crossover not not for a long time
but they could totally do war of Kings
that that involves a lot of Shiar
characters and a lot of guardians of the
galaxy based characters right now I
really think that Deadpool is the
connective tissue for Fox at this point
because his core operating mission is to
go around and kill different characters
it's a lot easier for him to logically
jump around from group to group to group
so he could be given a mission to kill
one of the x-men he appears in an x-men
movie he could be given a mission to
kill mr. fantastic so he shows up in
their movie the clicks and to all that
that's slowing everything down is just
you know like like the backroom deals
that need to be made to get actors to
appear in all these different movies
it's one thing to sign an actor to a
single franchise but when you want to
use them at a bunch of other movies it
just gets way more complicated that
being said the Fantastic Four cast Ryan
Reynolds the cast of the x-men movies
they're all really nice people so they
all want to see crossovers too so what's
gonna happen tonight is is they're gonna
air the red band trailer on Conan
that'll be in like it like two or three
hours depending on what time I post this
video at I'll do a video right after so
just keep your
eyes peeled on my twitter and facebook
for updates on that what I'm gonna do
for fantastic for it I'll be seeing it
Thursday night so I'll do a non-spoilery
review then I'll do like an Easter Egg
video like I do for all my other comic
book movies after that so there'll be
two different videos for that so you'll
know like which ones non spoilery if
you're not gonna be seeing the movie
right away if you have an IMAX theater
nearby or like a 70 millimeter theater
go see it at one of those they'll be
playing the Deadpool trailer in front of
that so you'll be able to see it in like
nice big shiny format the videos that I
make are intended to be watched on like
you know really small phones but movies
like Deadpool Fantastic Four they're
meant to be seen on like giant big
screens so it just it's so much more fun
when you go to see it at a theater
because they just dropped a DC TV bump
they just announce who's gonna be
playing Vandal Savage and who's gonna be
playing Hawkman on legends of tomorrow I
mean I mean he'll be on arrow in the
flash - but I'm gonna do a separate
video for that this should post tomorrow
morning so it's actually a really
exciting week despite the fact that it
is like the most boring part of the
summer so why you guys wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here for the
Deadpool teaser video and you can click
here to learn all about his origin story
in the comics thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you